Let's take the video of Philando
castile's death.
So that was,
um,
shot by his,
his fiance and her readiness with her
phone.
And her quick instinct to use facebook
live is very,
was very potent in that video.
People may remember that,
um,
she is watching her fiance bleed to
death and at the same time calling out
to two entities to witness her.
The first is God and the second is
facebook.
So she wants our witness the purpose
that we as users,
as responsible users,
as humane users of the Internet have.
Our responsibility is to bear witness in
that way.
Um,
not to experience it ourselves so much
as to testify to the fact of the fact
that it happened to serve as a massive
jury of peers who would,
who give credence to the experience of
other people.
And in that way,
I think that was a,
an extremely profound moment in the way,
crystallizing the way that we all use
facebook when we use it,
right?
Or use twitter when we use it.
Right.
You know you have Newt Gingrich even now
saying we don't have white white
Americans don't understand the
experience of black Americans and that
chasm,
that gap and understanding has been one
that the Internet is in large part
responsible for that.
There's a huge vocabulary.
There's a set of symbols.
There's,
you know what I think of as an idiom
set,
but also a testimony about experience
that we weren't,
that of each of each of us have each of
us in different dialects,
that we weren't allowed or we,
we didn't have access to communally
share.
Now we are,
as some people say in this adolescence
with this,
with digital culture and we're trying
to,
to determine what to do with this
infinitely polyglot culture speaks so
many different languages.
You know,
I was reading because why not?
I was reading Henry James as account of
being at Ellis Island at the beginning
of the last century and his horror at
what he calls the teaming and squirming
massive flooding onto into New York,
which now we would see as politically
appalling,
as a level of,
of,
of disgust that goes hand in hand with
certain,
you know,
antiseptic right wing nativists
thinking,
especially coming from a waspy.
You know,
Henry James figure mirrors almost
exactly the vocabulary that people use
when they describe twitter.
When they described the youtube
comments.
These people are illiterate,
they're angry,
they're squirming and teeming.
That is a natural reaction to people who
feel like they belong here and their
spaces being seized by people whose
language they don't speak,
who are,
you know,
in many,
many ways alien to them.
But the Internet shows us over and over
again and the billions of us who use
facebook,
no,
that that exposure is not only necessary
but good for us,
but good for us.
It's exposing our immune system to test
over and over to different means that
confront our bodies the way microbes do
and raise our immune system.
Ask us to be more robust citizens.